zum ersten mal in der geschichte der
menschheit ist gestern ein autonomes
fahrzeug auf einem planeten gelandet um
dort gezielt nach lebens zu suchen es
ist der technisch entwickelte rover der
jemals von menschenhand entwickelt wurde
gestern um 21 44 ist er auf spektakuläre
art und weise gelandet 11 minuten und 22
sekunden später erreichten die signale
der erde und er hat ein gerät dabei das
eine absolute ja universums premiere ist
krieg zum science im future gibt es
dreimal pro woche spannende videos aus
der wissenschaft abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
pixum gibt es ja auch auf die ohren und
es ist einer der populärsten science
podcast in deutschland der link zum
podcast sie runter und unten in der
video beschreibung zum spotify und apple
podcasts ja und da mache ich ja was
besonderes inzwischen das heißt es gibt
immer mehr infos zum thema was war das
gestern abend für ein jubel alles hat
wie am schnürchen geklappt der
mars-rover börse wir uns wurde an seilen
von einem skytrain einem himmels kram
abgesetzt eine technologie die die nasa
bereits 2012 bei mars rover curiosity
erstmals erfolgreich eingesetzt hat hoch
komplex aber die beste art und weise
schwere lasten auf dem mars abzusetzen
vorher hatte die landeeinheit ihr
hitzeschild abgesprengt entfaltet in den
fallschirm und zündete dann die
triebwerke des skytrains und um 21 55
hieß es touchdown nach einer 200 drei
tage dauernden reise durch den weltraum
und sofort funkte person wir uns zwei
noch etwas staubige bilder an die erde
wenn die hochauflösende panorama kamera
aktiviert wird dann wird es die
spektakulärsten bilder geben die wir je
vom mars gesehen haben aber der neue
rover hat noch andere bahnbrechende
technik an bord er soll konkret nach
leben so kommt insgesamt acht jahre lang
haben forschungsteams der nasa an dem
insgesamt 2,2 milliarden euro teure mars
rover gearbeitet sein name ist
hoffentlich programm denn presse wir uns
bedeutet übersetzt so viel wie
durchhaltevermögen beharrlichkeit
insgesamt hat der hofer 472 millionen
kilometer zurückgelegt und ist jetzt
eben
zero creator ein ausgetrockneter see
gelandet ein ort der zuvor noch niemals
genauer unter die lupe genommen wurde
hier soll der rover nach lebensform
suchen die möglicherweise auf dem mars
existiert haben dazu der nasa
wissenschafts direkter thomas zu buchen
der giro krater ist der perfekte ort um
nach zeichen vergangenen lebens zu
suchen so können wir verstehen wie der
mars einmal war und warum man nun so ist
wie er ist zunächst soll perso wir uns
also nach gesteinsproben suchen die im
jahr 2031 mit hilfe einer weiteren raum
sonne zur erde zurückgebracht werden
sollen ganz vorne mit dabei die
europäische weltraumagentur esa der
ehemalige chef des nasa mars programm
scott hubbard hatte proben vom roten
planeten mal als zitat heiligen gral der
mars wissenschaften bezeichnet die
fachleute jedenfalls sind sich sicher
dass providence uns auf der intensiven
suche nach leben einen großen schritt
nach vorne bringen wird dazu der
inzwischen zurückgetretene nasa chef jim
brittens sein wir wissen nicht ob dort
leben existiert hat oder nicht aber wir
wissen dass der mars in seiner
geschichte einmal bewohnbar
wittenstein war von trump 2018 zum nasa
chef ernannt worden und erklärte bereits
am 19 januar einen tag vor der
amtseinführung zur beides seinen
rücktritt briten stein war umstritten
weil er vor seiner ernennung zum
nasa-direktor den klimawandel geleugnet
hatte und kein naturwissenschaftliches
studium vorweisen konnte mit seinem weg
an steht das artemis programm die
mondlandung 2024 auf der kippe die frage
ist ob die neue administration während
der pandemie bereit ist erhebliche
summen in ein solches projekt zu stecken
das nur am rande
anfang 2000 20 hatten die nasa fachleute
presseevents instrumente im heißen und
kragen südaustralien getestet und zwar
mit erfolg dafür hatte das australische
forschungsteam nachbauten der
originalinstrumente von percy wir uns
auf die spurensuche in einem gebüsch zog
in der nähe von adelaide geschickt dazu
die astrobiologin bonität die gegend
dort eignet sich sehr gut um forschung
zu betreiben wie auf dem mars es ist ein
trockenes staubiges und windiges gebiet
sehr karg das eine gute analogie bietet
um wie auf dem mars nach leben zu suchen
die instrumente sollten in den felsen
die besten stellen identifizieren die
möglicherweise biomarker
komponenten oder fossilien von
mikroorganismen enthalten könnten
mit am start waren ein röntgen
instrument eine kamera mit hoher
auflösung in der ferne und ein
spektrometer das bio signaturen
aufspüren soll um messfehler
auszuschließen müssen verschiedene
instrumente eindeutige hinweise liefern
und genau das war passiert die person
ins instrumente konnten über 500
millionen jahre alte spuren des lebens
aufspüren die instrumente haben damit
den test gut bestanden auf dem mars
selbst ist geplant dass der rover nicht
nur gesteinsproben nimmt die zur erde
gebracht werden sollen auch die
marsoberfläche soll er detailliert
analysieren
ein us forschungsteam hat jetzt gerade
noch einmal bestätigt dass das
angepeilte untersuchungsgebiet auf dem
roten planeten gut gewählt ist im
bereich des siegers zeichnen sich
nämlich höchstwahrscheinlich reste eines
einstigen flussdeltas ab und das ist für
die suche nach spuren von leben
natürlich äußerst erfolgversprechend
auch modellsimulationen machen große
hoffnungen denn sie offenbaren dass der
fluss im giro krater mögliche
mikrobielle lebensform auf der
marsoberfläche einst fortgetragen haben
könnte und sie sich somit geschützt
unter den sedimenten abgelagert sein
könnten dazu der forscher matula potro
es sollen bei der mission die ersten
proben entstehen die für untersuchungen
vom mars zur erde gebracht werden das
ist sehr aufregend denn es könnte sich
damit die chance ergeben einblicke in
die entstehung von leben auf einem
anderen planeten zu gewinnen und somit
auch die frage was leben überhaupt ist
providence hat in etwa die größe eines
kleinen autos und ist rund 1000
kilogramm schwer
es ist der fünfte und bislang technisch
kompliziertes der mars-rover der usa
denn nicht nur alle negativen sondern
auch positiven erfahrungen die die nasa
in den vorherigen missionen gesammelt
hatte wurden bei der planung und dem bau
von percy wir uns berücksichtigt denn er
verfügt nicht nur über einen roboterarm
und 20 kameras sondern auch über einen
mini hubschrauber und das ist eine
absolute premiere er ist jetzt noch im
inneren des rovers zu seinem schutz
untergebracht er hat exakt die größe
eines klubs 10 x 10 x 10 cm und wiegt
nur 1,8 kilogramm und für die dinge mars
atmosphäre musste er besonders
konstruiert werden nicht nur dass er
besonders klein und leicht ist seine
beiden gegenläufigen rotoren drehen sich
mit 3000 umdrehungen pro minute das ist
etwa zehnmal schneller als sich die
rotoren bei helikoptern hier auf der
erde drehen die stromversorgung des
helikopters funktioniert über
solarzellen und lithium ionen akkus wie
die landung von persiens muss auch die
steuerung des hubschraubers automatisch
erfolgen die erde ist zu weit entfernt
um ihn in echtzeit steuern zu können
der enthält zwar grobe fehler aber wir
sie dann umsetzt das ist seine sache
stehen erstmal flugtests auf die
emissions- plan
beim ersten test wird er nur drei meter
nach oben abheben und dort etwa 30
sekunden verharren danach sind bis zu
fünf weitere flüge geplant dabei soll er
sich immer weiter vom ufer entfernt
schließlich soll das fluggerät einige
hundert meter weit fliegen und
anderthalb minuten unterwegs sein mit
diesem helikopter können dann in zukunft
entfernte gebiete fotografiert und
kartiert werden und so region untersucht
werden die anrufer nicht erreichen kann
und zudem kann der hubschrauber ständig
das gebiet um den hofer untersuchen und
so bei der auswahl des nächsten
interessanten features unterstützen
auch deutsche wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler haben zu der
herausragenden technik beigetragen so
sind unter anderem thermo sensoren des
leibniz instituts für photonische
technologien in jena mit am start sie
ermöglichen es die oberflächentemperatur
des planeten zu messen und das ganz ohne
berührung es wird sehr sehr spannend was
der rover in den nächsten monaten und
jahren für erkenntnisse gewinnt
vielleicht findet er ja tatsächlich
spuren von leben leben auf dem mars
schon längst entdeckt sehr spannendes
video von tim von astor comics tv also
anklicken anschauen und den kanal
unbedingt abonnieren erst kurz vor
50.000 abos und ich drücke ihm die
daumen dass er die auch wirtschaft und
ihr könnt ihn dabei unterstützen bis
dann bleibt dran